[Música]
Hola Bienvenidos a revista digital donde
abordamos los temas más importantes del
ciberespacio las redes sociales y los
medios de comunicación de América Latina
y el mundo un chatbot está causando
sensación entre los usuarios de internet
por la infinidad de tareas que puedes
realizar se trata de chat que utiliza la
Inteligencia artificial para simular
diálogos y crear canciones e historias
tan solo con enviarle un mensaje de
texto Pero eso también genera
preocupación sobre los procesos de
aprendizaje y hasta la propagación de la
desinformación lo analizamos en esta
misión empezamos
de la compañía Open as sigue dando de
qué hablar desde sus lanzamiento a
finales de 2022 se trata de un chatbot
que usa la Inteligencia artificial y
está diseñado para imitar conversaciones
similares a las humanas puede responder
a una infinidad de preguntas y realizar
diversas tareas que van desde Traducir
crear canciones poemas e historias y
hasta realizar ensayos con las pautas
que usted le entregue fue entrenado para
predecir qué palabras sigue en una
secuencia de palabras por ello da la
impresión de que usted está hablando con
otra persona al otro lado de la pantalla
para su entrenamiento se usó una amplia
cantidad de textos de internet por lo
que también puede estar propenso a
replicar prejuicios y sesgos presentes
en la información que le fue entregada
veamos ahora algunos ejemplos de cómo
reacciona charge pity a las solicitudes
que le hacemos y le voy a pedir entonces
que ordene de menor a mayor los
siguientes números que ustedes están
viendo en pantalla y ahí podemos ver
como los ordena del menor que es el
número 6 hasta el más grande que es el
número 678 ahora le voy a pedir algo más
original le voy a pedir que produzca una
historia descabellada le voy a pedir que
escriba en 30 palabras la historia de
una máquina que aprendió a presentar
noticias en France 24 y ahí lo pueden
ver cómo está relatando la historia con
las pautas que le di y ahora Miren lo
que pasa cuando le pido que escriba una
carta como si fuera una persona que no
cree en la efectividad de las vacunas ya
habíamos mencionado que podía replicarse
medios o sesgos presentes en la
información que se utilizó para su
entrenamiento ya que trata de millones
de textos que circulan en internet miren
por ejemplo que cita retóricas típicas
de los antivacunas como son la
efectividad y la seguridad y también
los posibles efectos secundarios aquí
cabe Resaltar que todas las vacunas que
han sido aprobadas por las autoridades
sanitarias No solo son efectivas sino
que también son seguras
para el análisis vamos a conectar con
Samir Estefan él es experto en
tecnología y ceo de T etcétera También
Bienvenido a France 24 hay ahora mismo
todo un debate sobre cómo tecnologías
como chía gpt afectan el aprendizaje y
la creatividad cuando ya hay una máquina
que lo hace todo por uno y que podría
prestarse para fraudes
Sí yo creo que ese es el debate más
grande que tenemos en este momento pero
no es un debate nuevo o sea este debate
lo tuvimos cuando apareció el internet
este debate lo tuvimos cuando apareció
el computador este debate lo tuvieron
los los arquitectos y los ingenieros
cuando aparecieron las herramientas Cat
este debate lo tuvimos cuando apareció
la calculadora yo lo que pasa es que
creo que necesitamos entender que el
mundo está cambiando que el mundo va a
seguir cambiando y que tenemos que
asegurarnos que estas herramientas las
podemos utilizar no prohibir pero sobre
todo que las podemos incorporar al
proceso educativo en un modelo que haga
sentido sí y en el cual podamos
controlar por ejemplo el plagio o que la
gente no haga las tareas completamente
pero no deberíamos prohibirlas porque al
final del día y de nuevo reitero el tema
del uso por ejemplo de cad si tú miras
los arquitectos que se negaron a
utilizar Cat en sus clases hace 25 años
pues seguramente hoy no tendrán trabajo
el trabajo de esos arquitectos han
cambiado y así empezar con el resto de
las labores que hacemos o que harán los
jóvenes en el futuro ya se hablan en las
instituciones educativas sobre bloquear
esa tecnología de hecho en la ciudad de
Nueva York se prohibió su acceso para
evitar Por así decirlo que los alumnos
hagan trampa es esta la solución
Yo creo que la primera razón es el
entender cuál es la razón de un de una
institución educativa sí la razón de la
educación es preparar a los a los niños
y a los jóvenes para el futuro al que se
van a enfrentar y el futuro al que se
van a enfrentar es claramente un futuro
en el que va a haber gente que utilizará
herramientas de Inteligencia artificial
para su trabajo como ya hoy se hacen
finanzas en medicina etcétera etcétera y
bloquearles digamos la posibilidad de
aprender a utilizar esto los va a dejar
en desprender en desventaja dicho eso
hoy ya Ayer esta semana vimos un anuncio
grande de parte de oppenheid de una
herramienta que sirve para validar si un
texto fue escrito por ellos o no Y de
nuevo Yo creo que tenemos es que
incorporarlo y dejar de medir y dejar de
poner exámenes o notas que Sencillamente
buscan un resultado y que no le permite
a la gente ser creativa y utilizar estas
herramientas como ya pasa por ejemplo
los exámenes de cálculo y de
trigonometría ya la respuesta no es lo
importante Lo importante es cómo
llegaste a ese resultado porque la gente
ya utilizar una calculadora para sacar
esa respuesta
Samir también se habla de que este tipo
de programas por ejemplo pueden llegar a
reemplazar a los humanos debemos estar
asustados
yo yo te diría que al final no va a ser
la Inteligencia artificial la que nos va
a reemplazar sino que va a ser alguien
que sabe utilizar la inteligencia la
Inteligencia artificial la que
reemplazará a aquellos que no hoy lo
vemos y te pongo un ejemplo grande por
ejemplo en detección de cáncer hoy en
día son más aquellos médicos que que no
saben utilizar la Inteligencia
artificial y que no tienen acceso a esos
algoritmos que aquellos que sí pero
estamos viendo mejores resultados de
aquellos que utilizan su conocimiento
mezclado a la capacidad de Inteligencia
artificial aquí va a pasar lo mismo lo
digamos el reto y el susto que hay Es
que esto le está pegando a más
actividades nos está pegando a
periodistas a bloggers a estudiantes a
escritores etcétera etcétera entonces ya
la gente lo ve un poco más cerca pero el
camino natural de herramientas como
estas es que se incorporen y que la
gente aprenda a utilizarlas para ser más
productivos en la labor que cada uno de
ellos
realice era Samir Estefan experto en
tecnología con el análisis aquí en
France 24 de esta manera despedimos este
capítulo de revista digital recuerde que
si quieres repetir esta u otra misión de
nuestro programa lo pueden hacer A
través de nuestra página web triple W
punto com
[Música]